my name is young Perko I work on the
blue cloud team and I'll give a brief
introduction to what the cloud is about
what we've been working on over the last
year and what new features you can
expect in the future
hello and welcome everyone my name is
yun pesckow I work on the Wolfram cloud
team and today I want to talk about what
we've done over the last year or so and
what new features you've maybe already
seen or what you can expect in the in
the future first of all what's what's
the Wolfram cloud I think it provides
many different things first of all it
allows you to work note work with
notebooks and write Wolfram language
code write in a web browser without
having to install anything on your local
machine and you don't need Mathematica I
don't need any browser plugin you can
just go to google.com and get going
but even if you work with tester
Mathematica it can be very useful to use
the cloud as sort of a deployment target
you can share notebooks with others who
might not have Testament America whether
that's individual persons or just the
whole world basically and you can also
deploy arbitrary web applications
written in Wolfram language to the cloud
that could be could be notebooks again
but it could also be forms or API is
that perhaps even return arbitrary HTML
so you could build an actual web
application which might not be using
notebooks at all so it's very versatile
I would say to focus a little bit on
tests cloud notebooks your a few things
you can do with them and and by the way
this is running in a cloud notebook
right now so you can see this is a web
browser connected to port from cloud
comm it just happens to be a notebook in
in slideshow mode running in the cloud
right now so you can you know enter some
text as usual in the in in a notebook
interface you can make evaluations as
usual of course it can be more
complicated math that returns a formula
like this
and one more important thing is that
this is rendered purely in the browser
on the client side so as a post an image
this you can actually resize this and it
and it adapts so it's not just a bitmap
rendering of of this formula of course
you have support for 2d and 3d graphics
like like this one see the cell brackets
and this is interactive you can rotate
this you also support manipulates like
this ones you could move around locators
and track around the sliders and this
basically just works again in in a web
browser without any any local
installation so yup that's that's cloud
notebooks and you know to get something
into the cloud you can just create
things on the cloud in the first place
or from desktop Mathematica you would
use publish to cloud or safe to cloud to
to get it on to Wolfram cloud calm so
now a few things that that changed over
the last year or so first of all we
simplified the landing page and so the
the onboarding process which which i
think is really nice so now if you go to
tool from cloud comm if you if you
logged in you see a much cleaner
interface and also if you if you're not
logged in yet so in this incognito
window you get a landing page which
actually explains what's going on in the
cloud and then you have one way to to
sign up it's actually free so to create
a basic plan you just need to create a
Wolfram ID with your email address and
and that's it basically
if you then need more computing
resources in the cloud and you might
have to upgrade to to a paid plan but
even with the basic plan you get quite a
lot I think oops
so yeah we're not completely done yet I
would say with this streamlining of
products in some sense it could still be
a little bit confusing what product you
choose but I think we've come a long way
and so so yeah this is quite good as
part of this we've already changed the
URL structure slightly you know the URL
structure of cloud objects and I think
this is something important to keep in
mind when you work with the clouds I'm
gonna explain this a little bit by
default what you get from functions like
cloud deploy and cloud publish is a URL
that has obje
in it like here and that refers to what
we call the the object or the deployed
view of an object and this is meant to
be you know that the URL that you share
with other people usually so if you if
you look at that manipulate that's
rollin it would it would look like this
it has a small header on top but
otherwise it's really just a notebook
that you can interact with whereas in
the environment view you can also edit
the notebook and you can actually
construct that programmatically
using the the optional cloud object your
L type to cloud object so in this view
you know we get a little more header and
then the sidebar here and then you can
actually edit the notebook here so yeah
that's what that's what we call the
environment U and that's also what you
would get if you create a new notebook
on Wolfram cloud com
of course you get into the dis editing
environment there's a few key
differences between these environments
that are good to keep in mind so this
environment view is only available to
authenticated users so if you shared
this link with someone else that has env
in it they will be asked to log in first
before they can see the notebook whereas
the object view that's meant for public
consumption
basically so as soon as you have
permission to see the notebook
in this case would have to be public
anyone could look at a notebook in the
object view as well we mentioned in the
environment view you can do pretty much
anything that you have to permit that
you have permission to with the notebook
including editing a notebook and if you
have read permission you can also save
it back whereas in this object view you
can only read and interact with the
notebook even if you would have more
permissions there's also a difference in
the kind of kernel that you get in each
of these views it's sort of a technical
detail but but maybe you care about this
so in the environment view you basically
get a longer leaf section kernel because
the idea is really that you know you do
some experiments you define variables
and use them later as you would usually
in in in a notebook session or is in the
public view or the object view you get
what we call a public kernel which is
shorter lifts and you know you can't
assume that it that it sticks around for
a long time yep
yes great point yeah it's it's really
different views on the same object yep
absolutely so if I close this and Oh for
some it's usually not a good idea to
have two versions of the same notebook
open at the same time that's a little
caveat right there and I think it
actually showed this but if I know I
should be able to edit this and if I
wait for it to save and yeah as I switch
to the obj view now and now I have this
edit here as well yep
it depends so for instance for an API
function you would usually only view it
in the deployed view but that's where it
actually executes we we think of this
deployed view as sort of the yeah the
thing you would usually use like if you
if you like if you open an executable on
your local machine right versus the
environment view is is the editing
environment where you would yeah mmm
have have a richer interface that allows
you to edit thing things yep so we did
certainly document this cloud object URL
type optional but we certainly want to
add more documentation about just you
know just what I explained now it's sort
of a higher level overview of how the
cloud operates that's that's something
we still need to do absolutely and I
also want to mention that it's usually
not a good idea to rely on this
structure of URLs in your code anyway so
it's certainly no great to to use a
function like this where you use this
option to change from one URL tab to
another but you shouldn't make any
assumptions about this URL other than
that so don't go in and you know fiddle
with the string and adjust it somehow
because we might be making more changes
to this URL structure in the future of
course we'll announce that and and talk
about it but in your code is usually not
a good idea to rely on that
implementation detail yeah
and other than then your else and
Chrome's there's also a difference in
terms of cloud credits so in the
environment view it basically doesn't
matter what you do you have your single
session kernel you can do evaluations
without having to worry about cloud
credits at all in the object view that's
that
slightly different so if if you have an
API functional form function for
instance they would always consume cloud
credits as they execute part of the
reason is of course that you know you
could share something with the whole
world and it might be by using lots of
cloud resources in parallel if multiple
users try to try to access the object at
the same time so we need to control for
that somehow at the same time and
Stephen and Andre have already talked
about this as well we realized that
especially if you just publish a
notebook you usually don't want to worry
about clouds credits you just want to
get it out there and my internet mm-hmm
see what happens should refresh this you
do need internet connection to work with
the clouds that's the unfortunate
reality so far so yeah the idea is that
as long as you publish a notebook making
it public we would provide every viewer
with sort of complimentary amount of
cloud credits so that you as the owner
of the notebook don't have to worry
about them you know once once each
viewer runs out of that limit we might
ask him to sign in or something but it
would never it would never use your own
cloud credits so this is kind of a
problem
we make sense you try the other Wi-Fi or
is that hopeless okay there it is again
otherwise I do have a local cloud
installation okay so yeah right so
question was about collaboration in the
environment view its it doesn't work
very well right now yeah that that is
the unfortunate short answer it's
something we definitely want to support
in longer term so that multiple people
could work on the same notebook at the
same time right now it's it might be a
bit unpredictable usually what should
happen is that one person gets the lock
on the notebook and then one person can
edit it the others can still look at the
notebook and usually what might happen
is that they even see the updates but
there is no no guarantee for that I'd
say yeah but definitely something we
want to do in the longer term yeah so
now I just want to go over a few new
features that we developed over the last
year in in cloud notebooks some of them
are just to base we catch up with
desktop and what's supported there
others are actually unique cloud
features at least for now
and this first one is is one of those
part of the motivation was though to to
reach the gap a little bit between cloud
and desktop because you can't right now
you can't edit typesetting constructs in
the cloud as such you can certainly
evaluate something like this and then
you get something back that renders as a
fraction you can even copy that and and
paste it into an input cell and then you
can edit around it so the Sabre
you can't go into this and and edit just
the numerator for instance but one thing
we added so that you can enter these
things into an input cell right away is
this input form based input so you press
control-shift one and then you you enter
what's called input form and in word
from language so for a fraction that
would just be X slash wild and you press
ENTER and it resolves to the fraction
right in place now if I want to edit
this I can just click it and it goes
back to this linear form again and of
course this also has the right
evaluation semantics so I can you know
put this like this and doing yeah and it
and it treats it like like a regular
fraction of course a bit similar is
evaluate in place which does exist on
desktop of course so if you select
something in input cell and press
command enter on Mac it resolves to the
result right away so that's also useful
sometimes and then you can keep working
with it in the same cell if maybe
already seen it we also added something
called click to copy so if you have a
result like this you just need to click
the output cell and it's immediately on
the clipboard you can then paste it
somewhere else and and keep editing it
and part of the motivation was again
that you can't really make a granular
selection in here so unfortunately at
this point I can't select just the
numerator of this fraction so it just
makes sense to copy the whole thing we
also added support for cell group
openers and closures so if you close a
cell group like here you get this little
icon and also the corresponding closer
once you open it we also added print to
PDF so in the in the file menu you now
have this item and it will take a little
bit because it takes this whole
slideshow
but eventually it it should generate a
nice PDF which you know you could then
print or share it with others
and in a sense this is just another view
of this cloud object again so notice
that instead of obj or env we have PDF
now here so we might actually add this
to the language level as well to easily
construct such URLs in the first place
few more things we also added support
for Unicode Unicode so you can now you
know at least a Mac press something like
ctrl command space and insert unicode
characters or emojis in particular and
they also have the the right evaluation
semantics so it treats this string as
just having a single character with this
copán yeah you can also the you know a
good code yeah it's just going to show
that so that's the one caveat right now
is that under the hood our editor is
still sort of 16-bit based as far as
characters are concerned so you'll see
that the cursor goes into this emoji now
if you know I want to live adventurous
in a sense yeah so you could add
something here and it breaks up the
surrogate pair but don't do that yeah so
that's Unicode support we also worked a
bit on tokenization of code or text in
general and the spacing around tokens so
this is a screenshot from a previous
cloud versions from previous code
versions and this is what you would see
now so notice that the spacing got a
little more relaxed and it's definitely
more similar to the desktop now we also
change
font that we're using under the hood for
friending some of these special
characters there is still some small
differences to the desktop but that
might actually be bridged by changing
the desktop not not the cloud at some
point desktop might be using the same
font we're using now to render these
characters so yeah lots of things going
on I can't go into detail for all of
them but the the overall focus of us has
certainly been no improved ability
robustness and performance in the cloud
and two projects I want to want to
highlight in particular because I think
they're quite interesting is first of
all client-side graphics rendering so so
far what we did to render any sort of
graphics in cloud notebooks was to use
the servers at kernel and front-end to
generate some JSON data that we would
then turn into an SVG graphic in the
browser and that was a good approach
because it allowed us to support all
sorts of graphics right away but it did
have that performance overhead of going
to the kernel every time we render the
graphic so what we've started to build
is a complete implementation of the
whole graphics layer in the JavaScript
front-end on the one hand for better
performance obviously but also on the
other hand to support for instance
dynamic in places where it didn't work
before so in this case we have you know
a circle with a dynamic radius like here
and then two other circles that are just
sitting there statically and they also
have a slider that changes that radius
so now you can see that updating
dynamically and that's something that
didn't actually work before you would
have to wrap dynamic around the graph
the whole graphic expression which then
had also negative consequences for
performance so this is something that's
that's starting to work well now and in
this case for this simple dynamic it
doesn't even have to go back to the
kernel which is which is very
the only caveat is that so far we only
support discs and circles so it's it's a
very small initial step on the surface
but under the hood we really build out a
nice framework and we should be able to
to add more primitives quite soon will
probably take a little longer to get to
things like inserts and axes but the
good thing is that you know there's
always a fallback solution so all
graphics will certainly render in the
cloud if necessary by by using that
kernel based approach we have now right
the other performance project I want to
talk about briefly is the compiler in
the cloud and this is not working quite
yet but in the next version of the cloud
we will have a working compiler so you
can do things like this now I can't use
the Wolfram cloud comm because it's not
quite there yet but on my local cloud
instance I could create a new notebook
and evaluate this and and this will do
the right thing so I can this and and it
just works in the cloud as well so
that's certainly good to speed up
Wolfram language code in in cloud
kernels but it will also allow us to
build something which is you know I
already showed this last year it's not
what it's not done yet but this is this
really the first step to getting this to
work where the idea is that we can
compile certain manipulates so need to
enable this and then take this
manipulate and I think I usually have to
do it twice for some reason but now what
should be happening maybe it's maybe I
was asking for too much
yeah I think it's it's quite smooth so
so what's happening now is that it took
this expression inside the plot compiled
it to webassembly
which can run purely in the browser
without going back to the kernel and it
uses that to update the plot of a never
attract the slider so this this allows
for very smooth interactions that don't
suffer from the usual latency between
the client and the server side cloud
infrastructure so that's again a
long-term thing we're working on
enabling the compiler in the cloud is
the first step to that I'm running out
of time so I can't go into too much
detail but we've also worked on this
wolfram notebook and by the library you
can go to the website check out the
documentation it basically allows you to
seamlessly embed notebooks on websites
and in terms of integration we've also
worked on integration into Google Drive
so you can go to go to Google Drive if
you have a notebook file there just open
it and either you already have the
Wolfram cloud app connected or once you
do that it will suggest to open it and
we can do that really quickly I can just
say open this with Wolfram cloud it will
copy the file to the cloud open it there
you can already can edit edit the
notebook here if you want and then save
it back to Google Drive that's also a
nice integration particularly for
Chromebooks for instance so yeah that's
all I wanted to show today please reach
out either by email or in community
where we try to be quite active and also
if you want to learn more about each
release of the cloud we started to
publish these cloud release notes which
have lots of detail about each of our
releases looking forward to what you all
creating with the cloud and thanks for
your attention
you
[Applause]